Bitte schön.
Schönen guten Abend. Mein Name ist Dani Kocasarac. Ich bin heute die Dienstabende Artistin hier und würde jetzt gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, hauptsache jemand hilft mir.
Ja. Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Bescheidung sprechen, möchte ich ganz schnell Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen. Wie ist Ihr Name bitte?
Ich heiße Henrike Magau.
Magau.
Könnt ihr bitte Ihren Namen langsam beirren?
Ja, der Vorname H-E-N-R-I-K-E, Henrike.
Okay.
Und bitte?
Ja, und der Familienname Magau, M-A-G-E-R.
Okay. Frau Magau. Magau. Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt und bin geboren am 2.06.61.
61.
Okay. Frau Magau, wissen Sie Ihr aktuellen Gewicht?
Ja, ja, 78 kg wiege ich.
78, genau. Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
67.
67. Okay. Frau Magau, was führt Sie heute zu uns? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ja, also ich weiß gar nicht, was mit mir los ist.
Das hat so vor einer knappen Stunde angefangen, dass mir mit einmal extrem schwindelig war und auch schlecht.
Das ist mit einem Mal ist das gekommen, ja.
Und ich hatte so das Gefühl, der Boden schwankt unter meinen Füßen.
Und das war mir jetzt einfach so unheimlich, weil das auch so intensiver und weil ich das Gefühl hatte, ich kippe jeden Augenblick um.
Aber ich bin tatsächlich nicht umgefallen, aber ich hatte das Gefühl, ich habe überhaupt gar keine Stabilität.
Und es ist jetzt eigentlich auch immer noch.
Also mein Mann hat mich vorbeigebracht und hat mich begleitet bis hierher.
Ich hätte gar nicht alleine hierher kommen können.
Okay, Frau Magau, machen Sie sich keine Sorge, Sie sind jetzt bei uns.
Und ich würde gerne Ihnen empfehlen, aber jetzt möchte ich Schritt für Schritt über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen.
Seit einer Stunde ungefähr.
Ist Ihnen noch schwindelig?
Ja, mir ist jetzt auch schwindelig.
Ich muss mich festhalten und mir ist auch schlecht.
Ich muss mich gar nicht übergeben, aber ich habe immer so das Gefühl, ja.
Haben Sie nicht übergeben?
Nein.
Wie fühlen Sie diese Schwindel in einem Karussell?
Nein, nein, nein, der Boden wackelt unter mir.
Okay.
Das ist schon kurios.
Ich kann das natürlich überhaupt nicht gebrauchen.
Ich bin nämlich als Zugbegleiterin bei der Bahn beschäftigt.
Und da kenne ich das eigentlich.
Aber der Gedanke, dass ich jetzt in einem schwankenden Zug fahren müsste, ist völlig unvorstellbar.
Weil ich mich auf festem Boden schon kaum auf den Füßen halten kann.
Ja, Frau Magau, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge.
Aber erst mal muss ich diese Befragung beenden und danach werde ich Ihnen helfen.
Frau Magau, haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerte schon mal gehabt oder ist das erstmalig?
Nein, tatsächlich habe ich das schon mal häufiger gehabt.
Und ja, das hat vielleicht vor drei Jahren angefangen.
Und damals bin ich auch beim Haus aus gewesen.
Und der hat damals dann gesagt, ja, Ihr Blutdruck ist ein bisschen hoch und hat mir Medikamente verschrieben.
Und jetzt in der letzten Woche war das allerdings schon ein bisschen stärker.
Aber heute, also eben jetzt hat es überhaupt nicht wieder aufgehört.
Okay. Was meinen Sie häufiger?
Wie viel Mal haben Sie diese Attacken pro Woche oder pro Monat?
Also früher vielleicht ein, zweimal im Monat.
Und jetzt in der letzten Woche war das allein zweimal.
Zwei Mal.
Frau Magau, haben Sie weitere Beschwerte?
Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen, Brustschmerzen?
Ja, ja. Also heute habe ich auch Kopfschmerzen.
Ich fühle mich auch total schlapp.
Das ist aber auch schon seit längerer Zeit so, dass ich mich so ein bisschen antriebslos und schlapp fühle.
Und es schmeckt mir auch überhaupt nicht. Ich habe zurzeit überhaupt keinen Hunger.
Könnten Sie bitte über Ihre Kopfschmerzen ein bisschen erwähnen?
Wie ist die Kopfschmerzen? Wo genau? Und wie stark?
Also ich würde sagen, so ein Dröhnen im Kopf.
Und es ist aber auf beiden Seiten und im oberen Teil.
Also es ist erträglich. Ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel keine Tablette dagegen genommen.
Aber so, dass ich eigentlich das Gefühl habe, ich kann mich jetzt nicht gut konzentrieren oder so.
Konzentrationsprobleme haben Sie auch.
Okay, Herr Frau Magau, Sie haben schon erwähnt, Sie fühlen sich antriebslos.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerte?
Ach ja, das kann man immer so schlecht festlegen.
Also ich würde jetzt sagen, schon mehrere Wochen merke ich, dass es mir nicht so gut geht.
Haben Sie gleichzeitig Herzrausen, Herzglöpfen bemerkt?
Nie, mein Herz würde ich sagen, da merke ich nichts von.
Okay. Frau Magau, Sie haben schon erwähnt, Ihr Hausarzt hat gesagt, Ihr Blutdruck ist ein bisschen höher.
Ist das diagnostiziert bei Ihnen?
Ja, vor drei Jahren hat er das festgestellt und das nehme ich halt regelmäßig Tabletten.
Und da geht davon aus, dass das damit auch gut ist.
Ich nehme da Amlodipin und Bedockzock.
Amlodipin und Bedockzock, wie viel Milligramm und wie nehmen Sie diese Medikamente?
Ich nehme die beide morgens und Amlodipin ist fünf, was auch immer und Bedockzock ist 47,5.
Okay. Haben Sie weitere Vorerkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, erhöhte Blutdruckka?
Nee, eigentlich ist das das einzige, ich war immer ziemlich gesund.
Okay. Ist Ihre Blutdruck gut eingestellt?
Viel, ich weiß, ja. Ich kontrolliere den selber jetzt nicht so oft, aber immer wenn ich mal zum Hausarzt gehe oder auch mal bei Freunden bin, die ein Blutdruckmessgerät habe, dann messe ich mal.
Aber dann ist der eigentlich okay.
Ja, regelmäßig, Ihren Blutdruck zu messen ist sehr wichtig, Frau Magau, Sie machen das richtig.
Wann war Ihre letzte Messung?
Ach, das ist vielleicht so eine Woche her oder so.
Erinnern Sie sich die Ergebnisse?
Also das war irgendwie sowas bei 135, 138 zu 85 oder so.
Okay, das ist in normalen Bereichen, Frau Magau.
Jetzt bräuchte ich ein paar Informationen über Ihre gesundheitliche, allgemein gesundheitliche Zustand.
Fühlen Sie sich fiebrig oder haben Sie schützelfrost?
Nein, fiebrig fühle ich mich nicht.
Okay. Haben Sie kaltschweiß oder nachtschweiß bemerkt?
Nein, ich bin nicht aufgefallen.
Jetzt zurzeit ist es sehr warm, da schwitzt man nachts mal ein bisschen, aber nicht übermäßig.
Okay, Sie haben schon erwähnt, Sie haben keinen Lust auf Essen.
Haben Sie in den letzten Seiten ungewollt ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, so lange ist das ja auch noch nicht.
Ich habe nicht abgenommen, schön wäre es.
Das ist gut. Frau Magau, haben Sie Probleme mit Sturrgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, also ich bin ein bisschen verstopft, ja, aber nicht schlimm.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Probleme?
Ja, ich würde schon sagen, eigentlich hat das vielleicht angefangen, seit ich in einem Menopause bin.
Das ist schon 10 Jahre her.
Seitdem muss ich da immer mal ein bisschen gucken, gerade wenn ich auf Reisen bin oder so ein bisschen unregelmäßig lebe, dann klappt es nicht so gut.
Okay, haben Sie aber aktuell verstopft?
Ja, minimal.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlassen?
Nein, so glück nicht.
Okay, Frau Magau, Sie haben schon erwähnt, in letzter Zeit ist es ein bisschen warm. Trinken Sie ausreichend?
Ich denke schon.
Wie viel Liter ungefähr trinken Sie täglich?
Bestimmt 2 Liter, gerade wenn ich unterwegs bin, haben wir eigentlich auch immer eine Wasserflasche dabei.
2, 2,5 Liter trinke ich bestimmt am Tag.
Ja, das ist auch gut für Ihre Gesundheit, Frau Magau. Wie sieht Ihr Schlafqualität aus? Schlafen Sie gut?
Es ist schlafe ich eigentlich ganz gut, ja.
Okay, das freut mich. Frau Magau, sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Lassen Sie mich überlegen? Nein. Ich habe noch nie eine Operation gehabt.
Okay, sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverzweglichkeiten bekannt?
Zum Glück nicht, ich bin gegen, also ich wüsste nicht, dass ich gegen irgendwas allergisch bin.
Okay, das ist auch gut. Sie haben schon erwähnt, seit 10 Jahren sind Sie in Wechseljahre in der Pause.
Besuchen Sie Ihren Frauen arztregelmäßig?
Ja, eigentlich diese Krebsvorsorgeuntersuchung mache ich regelmäßig.
Okay, das ist auch gut.
Frau Magau, wie sind es fast durch noch ein paar Fragen? Rauchen Sie?
Seit 5 Jahren rauche ich nicht mehr, ich bin sehr stolz, dass ich das geschafft habe.
Aber ich habe viele Jahre geraucht, aber nicht so exzessiv viel.
Ich habe immer nur so ein halbes Päckchen am Tag.
Halbes Päckchen. Als man möchte ich sagen, das war richtige Entscheidung für Ihre Gesundheit.
Darf ich fragen, wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Das sind bestimmt, lassen Sie mich rechnen, 35 Jahre?
35 Jahre. Okay, nehmen Sie Alkohol zu sich?
Ja, je nachdem, wie ich arbeiten muss, wenn ich morgens früh aufstehen muss,
kann ich mir das natürlich nicht erlauben.
Ich trinke abends gerne mal eine Flasche Bier zum Abend.
Wir sind vielleicht 3-mal im Sommer, im Winter, 1-2-mal in der Woche.
Okay, ich nehme an, dass Sie nichts mit anderen Drogen zu tun haben.
Frau Magau, ist das richtig?
Ja, mit Drogen habe ich nie etwas zu tun.
Ja, das habe ich auch erwartet.
Frau Magau, sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Nein, beide sind relativ plötzlich gestorben.
Mein Vater hatte einen Schlaganfall und ist daran gestorben,
war aber auch schon im hohen Alter, muss man sagen.
Und bei meiner Mutter, da wissen wir gar nicht genau,
da hat auch letztendlich keiner danach gefragt,
die ist plötzlich verstorben, aber die war auch schon 82 Jahre alt.
Also irgendwie muss man damit enden, ihr wollt rechnen?
Ja, mein hat sich erst beileitet, dafür erst mal Frau Magau.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder, ja.
Ist er gesund?
Na, tatsächlich ist er überhaupt nicht gesund.
Ja, der hat so eine Verschlusskrankheit in den Beinen
und die musste tatsächlich schon an Unterschenkel amputiert werden,
weil das so schlimm war.
Ja, das tut mir sehr leid zu hören, es muss sehr schwer sein,
besonders für Ihren Bruder, Frau Magau.
Danke, Sie sind verheiratet, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, Kinder haben wir nicht, nein.
Und die arbeiten noch als Suche begleitet?
Ja, nicht mehr lange, aber im Augenblick bin ich noch berufstätiger.
Okay, treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nein, da komme ich eigentlich nicht dazu.
Okay, sind Sie in den letzten Monaten irgendwo hingeleist?
Ich meine Ausland, waren Sie im Ausland?
Ansonsten bin ich viel gereist, ja.
Im Ausland bin ich nicht gewesen, nein, gar nicht.
Hallo, ich bin sehr viel.
Frau Magau.
meinerseits habe ich alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Falls Ihnen noch etwas ein oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich will natürlich gerne wissen, was dahinter steckt.
Und kann mir das ja gar nicht erlauben, dass ich so durcheinander bin
und dass ich so schlecht auf den Wein bin, ja.
Ich muss ja gucken, dass ich regelmäßig wiederarbeiten kann.
Und insofern möchte ich natürlich schon wissen,
was dahinter steckt und was man dagegen tun kann.
Ja, Frau Magau, Ihre Sorgen sind nachvollziehbar,
aber sie sind jetzt bei uns und wir werden alles mögliche für Sie tun.
Erstmal würde ich so sagen, Sie sind in guten Händen.
Jetzt ist es zu früh, eine Diagnose zu stellen,
aber nach Ihrer Angaben habe ich vielleicht Verdacht auf,
dass Ihre Blutdruck entgleist oder haben Sie andere Erkrankungen.
Das wissen wir gerade nicht.
Dafür brauchen wir weitere Untersuchungen.
Jetzt würde ich Sie erst mal körperlich untersuchen
und ein paar Laborwerte bestimmen.
Ich würde Sie Blut abnehmen.
Und natürlich würde ich gerne bei Ihnen ein paar Bildgebende veranlassen.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Ja, ich würde gerne Ihnen eine Schädeltomographie durchführen.
Das klingt ungesund.
Das ist nicht schmerzhaft, Frau Magau.
Das ist eine besondere Bildgebende verfahren,
die wir schon jeden Tag zu häufig durchführen lassen.
Das ist eine, mit einer Tomographie können wir Ihre Gewebe
mit Schichtbilder überprüfen.
Und können wir die Ursache genau...
Ich glaube, ich habe schon mal Bilder in der Zeitung gesehen.
Ich merke, dass Sie etwas schmerzhaft bekommen,
aber das ist nicht zu viel.
Sie können jetzt einen Platz in den Märzbereich nehmen.
Dann komme ich gleich.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Sie bestimmt.
Ich denke, unsere Kollegen haben eine gute Gespräche durchgeführt.
Ich möchte sagen, wenn wir eine Entgleisung hipertensiv denken,
müssen wir Blutdruck messen.
Das ist das einzige, was ich denke,
das nicht so top war.
Sie hat gesagt, sie hat jetzt eine Schwindel- und Übelkeit.
Das wäre vielleicht ein Argument zu sagen,
wir gucken mal schnell, wir machen sogar EKG
und messen Blutdruck.
Damit wir im Augenblick nichts verpassen.
Weil der Patient hat gesagt,
im Notfall-Education Begleitung ihrer Mann.
Der Mann ist mitgekommen, weil sie selber gesagt hat,
sie wäre nicht mehr hingekommen in die Klinik und so.
Gut.
Okay, soll es weitergehen schon?
Können wir Arsatzgesprache anfangen?
Frau Bia, kannst du schon?
Ja, ich kann.
Okay, wir können einen guten Abend Frau Oberarztin.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Darf ich Ihnen kurz vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich. Wie haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ja, es handelt sich um Frau Henrike Mager.
Sie ist 63 Jahre alt, 1,67 kg, groß und 78 kg schwer.
Frau Mager stellt sich bei uns,
wegen seit einer Stunde bestehender Schwindel,
Vertigo und, ja Vertigo,
für ein Spägel-Education,
die eine neue Patientin hat.
Sie hat,
sie hat,
haben sie mit ihrem Mann in Begleitung von ihrem Mann gekommen.
Leidt ihr in Begleitung von ihrem Mann gekommen?
Ja.
Fragen nach Takikardi und Parkitation wurden verneint.
In letzter Zeit leiden sie auch unter Konzentrationsstörungen und Antriebslosigkeit.
An der vegetative Anamnese leiden sie unter Appetitlosigkeit und chronische Verstopfung, also Obstifation.
Sie trinken Wasser ausreichend.
An der Vorerkrankung leiden sie an Artilialehepartonie seit drei Jahren.
Sie gab an, dass ihr Blutdruck unter Kontrolle ist.
Die letzten Messung war vor zwei Wochen.
Das war 135,85 mm Quake Silber.
Daran nehmen sie regelmäßig am Lodipin 5 mg und Belockzog 47,5 mg einmal täglich.
Fragen nach Takikardi haben keine Veröffentlichungen und bei der Patientin keine Allergien.
Seit zehn Jahren sind sie in Menepause.
Frau Maga ist extraucherin, aber sofort haben sie 35 Jahre lang ungefährzehnt, die Zigaretten täglich geraut.
Sie trinken ein, zwei Flächen Biya, provokte und drogen Konsum wurde verleitet.
Zum Familienanamnese gab sie folgendes.
Ihr Vater ist an Apoplex gestorben und ihr Mutter ist mit 82 Jahre alt.
Sie haben einen Bruder mit PAVK, deswegen wurde ihr Bein amputiert.
Frau Maga ist verheiratet, hat keine Kinder, arbeitet als Zugbegleiterin.
Reiseanamnese ist leer und sieht Reibe kein regelmäßiger Sport.
Was ist Ihre Vermutung?
Aufgrund der anamnestischen Angabe habe ich auf eine Entgleitung der arteriellen Hypertonie.
Aber als Differenzialdiagnostisch kann ich auch Anämie, Hypothyrosis und Depression in Betracht sehen.
Ich würde erst mal Anämie sagen, aber ich habe die Patientin Entgleitung der Hypertonie gesagt.
Was machen Sie jetzt mit ihr?
Zur weiteren Abklärung würde ich die Patientin erst mal körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie da besonders?
Neurologische Untersuchung ist wichtig für die Patientin und wie Teilkörer mit wissen.
Was noch?
Und AKG?
Ne, was machen Sie als Erstes?
Sie haben ja schon gesehen die Patientin, aber worauf achten Sie noch?
Wenn Sie jetzt an Ihre Lieblingsdiagnose denken, verdachtsdiagnose denken, das wäre da auffällig.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Belästet vielleicht?
Hauskommariet, genau.
Das, was man sieht, deswegen habe ich auch die Augen gezeigt.
Und auch die Blutung der Lippen der Augen.
Gut, und was machen Sie noch mit ihr?
Ja, im Labor würde folgendes überprüfen.
Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter, Blutzucker, HBA, ins D, Theroidwerte.
Und was erwarten Sie?
Vielleicht können wir TSH ein bisschen eröffnet sehen.
Bei Anime würde ich natürlich sehen.
Hemoglobin, Ernest Richt.
Ja, genau.
Und sind dann eigentlich noch weitere Untersuchungen erforderlich?
Welche weiteren Untersuchungen würden sich dann denn anschließen?
Ja, die Patientin hat gewinnt, vertigo, deswegen würde ich einen HNO-Konstil erlassen.
Ach ja, klar.
Auf alle Fälle, ja.
Und was machen Sie noch?
Gehen wir mal davon aus, sie hat tatsächlich eine Anämie.
Was würde dann logisch folgen?
Ja, ich würde differenzial Blutbild sehen und weitere Laborwerte,
z.B. Eisen, Ferdin, Vitaminbase, World überprüfen.
Bildgebende?
Ja, als Bildgebende.
Sehr 63 Jahre alt würde ich bei der Patientin eine Koloskopie veranlassen.
Das war, worauf ich raus wollte, ob die irgendwo Blut verliert.
Ja, genau.
Sehr gut.
Ja, gut.
Untersuchen Sie die Patientin, halten Sie mich auf dem Laubenden, wie es ihr geht.
Und wenn sich das jetzt schon wieder normalisiert hat,
wenn Sie nichts Auffälliges finden, würden Sie die Patientin dann hier behalten
oder würden Sie sie wieder nach Hause schicken?
Wenn Ihre Blutdruck unter Kontrolle ist, würde ich die Patientin und natürlich,
wenn wir unsere Verdacht bestätigen, als sie eine Anämie hat,
würde ich die Ambulanz behandel und für weitere Untersuchungen
würde ich einen Termin einbauen.
Ja, sehr gut, wunderbar.
Ja, gut, ja, sehr schön.
Also, das war doch eine sehr, sehr gute Vorstellung.
Ich meine auch eine sehr komplette Wiedergabe des Fals.
Wir sind, glaube ich, auch, Dr. Gündes, gut in der Zeit, ne?
Ja.
Sehr, sehr gut, acht, zehn Minuten.
Und, also, ich würde sagen, das war wirklich sehr, sehr vollständig.
Eine Winzigkeit ist mir noch eingefallen.
War es nicht gefragt nach der Impfung?
Ja, Impfung, ja.
Ich verantwisse immer.
Warum komme ich drauf?
Also einmal natürlich, weil ich selber wieder erkältet bin
und eigentlich schon die ganze Zeit überlege, ob ich ein Corona-Test mache.
Und heute habe ich irgendwas gelesen, dass es einen neuen Corona-Impfstoff gibt.
Und dass man den für alte Leute aufreischt, aufreischt Impfung.
Und als ich irgendwie vor drei Wochen oder so beim Haus war,
haben die nämlich noch gesagt, sie wissen noch nichts Neues, ne?
Also relativ aktuell jetzt wieder Impfung.
Und insofern vielleicht auch so etwas, was in der Prüfung relevant ist,
dass man das doch alle fernlich vergisst.
Auch je nachdem, was die Patienten so haben.
Und ich glaube, ich habe dir das schon mal gesagt.
In letzter Zeit oder in den letzten Tagen oder Wochen oder so, ja?
In letzter Zeit ist die Zeit im Singular.
Ja, wir reden von vergangenen Zeiten.
Ja, das ist, wenn man ja aus alten Zeiten so in der Rückschau redet.
Aber in letzter Zeit Singular.
Aber ich glaube, das war wirklich sonst das Einzige, was war, ne?
Ja, eigentlich habe ich darauf, als du mich gewarnt hast.
Hast aber ja, ließ man.
Und ich glaube, irgendwas habe ich an Grammatik noch mal so schnell
zwischendurch verbessert.
Was mir eigentlich noch aufgefallen ist, weil das auch schon so ein bisschen,
weil jemand mit Schwindelsymptomatik vielleicht eine Frage ist.
Ich finde, eigentlich, ich habe mir einen schönen Beruf für die Frau ausgesucht.
Ja, die hat tatsächlich, ist sie irgendwas anderes.
Genau, im Original Fall ist sie Bäckerin.
Aber ich fand, dass er liebt mit der...
Herr Nicke Meier.
Natürlich.
Ja, Herr Dr. Gündiz kennt sie alle.
Er kennt sie alle, ohne Frage.
Ja, aber ich finde eigentlich, so eine Bahnschafflerin
hat heute echt ein mieses Job.
Und die sind halt auch, die haben ein ganz unregelmäßiges Leben.
Und haben, insofern, also eigentlich passt es auch zu jemandem,
der kinderlos ist, denke ich, ne?
Die haben unregelmäßiges Leben.
Und achten wahrscheinlich auch nicht so viel auf gesunde Ernährung
und das, was ich auf ihre Gesundheit.
Aber genau die kann natürlich diesen Schwangschwindel überhaupt nicht gebrauchen
bei ihrer Arbeit.
Und sie hat wechselnde Arbeitszeiten.
Sie ist praktisch immer auf Achse.
Und ist dazu auch noch in heutiger Zeit permanent Beschimpfungen ausgesetzt.
Ja, also das sind alles schon auch echte Stressfaktoren,
die man potentiell für so ein Burnout auch noch so mit anrechnen könnte.
Ja.
Hab ich auch nicht gebraucht, ja.
Aber wie gesagt, ansonsten wunderbar.
Ja.
So läuft es auch bei der Prüfung.
Ich hoffe auch so.
Danke.